hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the long-awaited return
of amnesia the Dark Descent we're gonna
finally play another custom story
because people have been asking for it
for a long time and I haven't played it
in forever and also people have been
demanding this particular custom story a
late-night drink you are a wine
enthusiast who's recently purchased a
new home while the house itself is nice
what drew you was news of a large wine
cellar left over by a previous owner
unswayed by the knowledge that he died
in a bout of insanity you have moved in
right away though you plan to wait until
morning to peruse the selection your
curiosity has gotten the better of you a
quick sip a quick sip a quick peek a
quick sip couldn't hurt could it or
maybe it'll unleash a whole bunch of
diabolical monsters that are gonna stab
me in the button haunt my darkest dreams
okay it looks like this might actually
be a longer one so I'm just going to say
yeah it has been a while since I played
amnesia the Dark Descent um I and and I
don't even think amnesia a machine fix
kind of counts because that didn't have
the same feel as the original amnesia
which holds a very special place in my
heart because it was obviously the first
game I ever did on my channel and I
actually really loved it it's got all
the best things it's um it's all the
best elements of a good horror game
combined into one it's not perfect by
any means and especially these custom
stories they're never perfect and but I
mean it really set the bar the new bar
for terror because I mean and these are
the Dark Descent was ingrained in
everyone's mind is like I bet you can't
play it for more than thirty minutes at
a time and I'm like hell yeah I can't
but that was just me anyway
thank you for playing my custom story
please enjoy oh I'm so ready who's
starting in a bedroom again
hello this title confirms ownership of
land blah blah blah to mr. Michael my
name is Michael apparently one man's
trepidation is another man's discount
okay so trepidation really cool word for
fear anything special here no this'll
there know do I've a lantern oh my old
thumpy thump and my brain filled with
brave juice and smartness juice and all
the other necessary juices to life mmm
so delightful it seriously has been
forever I mean I did this on a live
stream once but oh hello cellar door key
anything else any probably not usually
hide these in the top drawer no nothing
yeah probably nothing okay whoops I just
went in a circle yeah oh yeah I played
it on livestream but I did not take that
seriously or at least I didn't take it
very seriously but I am gonna take this
one seriously I'm sorry I missed you
today I have the intended dawn checking
in on okay that was me not that you to
make sure you were settled in I'm aware
that you have learned the fate of man
who lived here before you I apologize
for keeping the delicate matter from you
I've decided that I will tell you the
truth about everything regarding the
previous owner as I am certain you will
have any questions I will come early in
the morning try to get some sleep
huh but not early enough for me to steal
some wine and get delightful delectable
palates on my tongue
I bet the wine somehow tastes like blood
or something like that now I don't know
a lot about this one other than that
it's apparently a very good one this was
recommended to me by almost everyone if
you're playing going into these can get
dark down there it was I was um
recommended to me by a lot of you guys
and also a lot of other youtubers Reb
recommended this one to me Oh how are
you doing hmm
anything here of interest ladder where
do you go landlord told me that's just
an old storage area I don't need to go
there right now well if you say so
so okay how much oil I got oh they gave
me a full bar of oil oh I really I
really love the feel of amnesia I can't
get enough of it it's like my favorite
not my fit no it's kind of my favorite
locked landlord supposedly gave them his
recipes in the morning hopefully there's
a spare nearby open key key I already
looked kind of over here for the hell
would a key be I don't know oh maybe
there was a key over by um the lantern
that I didn't see probably behind a box
or something what was it oh oh look at
this tiny box oh it's so tiny oh I'm
gonna call you tiny box Tim you're gonna
come with me on an adventure tiny box
Tim maybe I got to smash you open in the
keys inside you know I'd never hurt you
I would never hurt you I just drooled
all over myself I would never hurt you
my little biscuit okay still haven't
found the key you smell a key around
here
do you smell key find those boxes the
boxes that bullied you cuz we're smaller
I'll kill him Joel oh yeah oh I can't
move there may be there yeah tiny box
Tim you are amazing I'm gonna - where'd
you go okay there you're hard to spot
you're rowdy
okay okay you coming with me baby let's
go into the darkness
oh it's Alexander house that fireplace
lit when the door was locked that the
landlord lighted earlier I'm gonna guess
no I'm gonna guess a whole lot of new
oh okay what else do I need where's that
wine baby give me that delicious blood
wine oh is it the one by all this
chemistry equipment I'm guessing it may
not actually be wine okay see the
motherlode which one to try calm your
tits yourself I'll try this one for now
mmm strain taste benefit interesting
I'll take this upstairs for the night
come with me tiny box Tim apparently I
just took part took of some wine I
didn't even notice it hmm I'm taking
this upstairs was this a forbidden wine
of umem baba and suddenly the mummies of
umem baba are gonna come kill me
oh why is this door locked I think the
landlord mentioned something about doors
locking when closed I hope I can find a
key
another key hunt well hopefully you tiny
box Tim tiny box Tim did I it is that
what occult you you'll be able to find
the way again oh maybe I can go oh maybe
there's a spare key or crowbar in the
storage area
you wait here tiny box Tim I'll be just
a moment actually you go scout ahead is
it dangerous
yeah okay thank you tiny box Tim I sure
hope nothing kills me whoa was that
under now excuse me what the hell was
that I saw shadow I never see shadows I
definitely don't have a shadow what was
that oh hello good good I'm glad you're
here oh it's just a spider yeah yeah
yeah you're with your bull honkey spider
anything under the bed nothing hello
okay oh good for you
hahaha really well then I seem to be
suffering a case of closet ception air
Oh oh my god oh look at that it's so
adorable oh okay
all right no no no no no no no no no no
no no no you don't do that [ __ ] to me do
not oh ah Thank You dynabox Tim I
haven't oh oh oh you [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] oh I haven't had a
custom sure you use mannequins on me
effectively in a while can't wait to see
what they cook up ha ha Hey look more
wait what if you're playing oh it's the
same note that's nice I like that
does that boxer oh he's there wait a
minute is that this okay no never mind
all right cool cool I like this already
tiny box Tammy will protect me from wait
a minute what wait a minute what what
the hell ah wait though signed my lord
namaha oh I'm gonna like this one
oh you [ __ ] where am I I'm lost I
should turn back
nope keep going forward that's the way
to go that's the way to do it oh wait
why do you think you should turn back
there's a door there for fighting on oh
we all ha ha if you're planning going to
the cellar time anytime soon please come
on we all miss you very much you are
going to die why am I gonna die and what
was back there tiny box Tim please help
me Oh No
how did I get how did I get here oh god
damn it you bastards ha ha I love it I
love it like it like it a lot
well that key said I need to get out of
here what okay music oh it opens anyway
okay all right then that's weird
okay Oh what the hell what is the deal
huh Jimmy Harlan
Oh just gonna oh okay
hi Billy all right then I got tiny bug
to her did why are you looking at the
water and not that guy over there uh hi
oh okay that's weird
ha ha we're okay
hi Alexander I seem to have taken a
whole wha what that was that oh my god
and I shouldn't have dragging the wine
I lost tiny box Tim oh I thought I
thought that might have been tiny box
Tim ha ha I had him I had him on my arms
you don't be [ __ ] with me like that
don't you be [ __ ] with me like that
oh my goodness ha ha dr. da da da da da
da da da da da da da da da da no hope
okay got it let me just take this loud
down a dumb sanity potions do that
boxing you're not the same as tiny box
Tim get out of here I'm sorry please
okay well it's a puller all right okay I
got it I got it I got it I got it baby
there we go whoa that is a long-ass
ladder that's a long-ass ladder
his last ladder s s ladder SS ladder ass
ladder ladder a slit I don't what I'm
not saying I know is that I'm climbing
up this infinite ladder Oh
oh this goes I'm sorry so trippy I love
it I love it this is a great return for
me to amnesia
do be okay da was weird what was in that
one I'm getting that wine was just pure
LSD it tastes funny and then just ah not
that I've ever taken LSD before and I
don't encourage it don't do it this will
happen to you maybe this does happen or
I okay this is kind of mildly serving
hell is going on here
hi can you answer okay never mind I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm you what what where
am I going
what happened I don't even know
sorry I got a new microphone I gotta
make sure I don't peek all over the
place don't have the settings quite a
hundred percent oh my god
that was awesome I don't even know what
happened Oh more climbing good yes
indeed I love this actually I do
oh this story so cool
I can do that too you want to have a
contest
everybody join me Oh Joe that was a good
one good job Joe really believed in
yourself Mary you could have picked it
up a little bit I'm just saying oh hi
that's why that guy was screaming I was
pulling on his neck until he died Oh mmm
that hi guys how's it going good you
good need some water it's plenty down
there oh goody
that looks like a sacrificial chamber
just a whole bunch of doors huh oh hi
when did you get there okay I picked the
wrong door
I see light is that a way out of here no
oh oh my goodness
thank you maybe no no I'm I'm enjoying
myself so much what is that what is that
what is that oh hello baby oh oh hello
baby you so hot you caught on fire now
please let me go I'm begging you let me
go wait no don't let me go oh don't let
me go baby oh God
whoa what the hell whoa oh oh oh it's
good
ah is good oh I love it I love it I love
it I won't be going back in there any
time soon I still got the bottle of wine
don't I did not bring it with me oh oh
it's good oh yeah it's so good
I love that ah okay I'm excited I'm
super excited for this custom store guys
I'm so excited for this custom story all
right but anyway enough gushing I'm out
of time for this part I cannot wait to
keep playing this oh it is so good okay
so anyway ah that's enough of me thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will
see you in the next
Oh
me
of me Elsie I'm an idiot
why did that scare me I have no idea I
just saw big shadowy figure to my saw
shadow
God tells be